oh we have to get off the plane this is
a cool entrance oven
guys take my tips
change your life change your life yeah
today is a special day why is it so
special because
we are going on a trip that is not to
the state yes we've been going to this
day almost every month for the last few
months more than every month yeah well
you yeah well that's right we're gonna
head to Paris let's go the reason why
we're going back to Paris is for our 10
years anniversary and next week
but uh well not bad but also because
um on our first anniversary Evan
surprised me to the to Paris we should
show we should show a clip from that
video right now hey hello big surprise
gotta go fast worse than my current get
in
oh okay what's happening this weekend is
our one year uh-huh I know I thought you
would remember yeah
I wanted to say that I love you
he's scary
[Laughter]
I don't know what's happening
it's something a little crazy a little
crazy
thought
the celebrate I love hold my hand
to celebrate our love but for this
weekend
and so for the weekend we got off to
Paris France no
what and we're on the way to the airport
right now are you serious
oh my God are you serious no way
before we go
we need to take these two dogs go for a
walk you go to a park Alex will be
taking care of them he's gonna stay over
our place you're gonna have fun with
Alex right Timo Timo Timo he wants to go
out for a walk that's why he's not when
I see the walk board he knows okay let's
go okay let's go go go go go let's go
foreign
[Music]
on our way to the airport
[Music]
so funny Evan just asked me how was the
bureau coming a lot and I said I'm a
great Vlog vlogger because I did not
film anything after we arrived
anyways we still love you I always love
you cheers
yeah we arrive at the airport now it was
very fast
um cheers
we went through the security very
quickly and then found the lounge and
we're just relaxing have some food and
wait for our flight
I was working after I feel myself
because I had to take care of something
and I didn't feel anything again anyways
right now we need to head to our gate
and get on board
all right we avoid it Yep this is Evan's
seat this guy fancy yeah
it's a lie down so that's why I picked
you
[Music]
all right not so good at news we were
waiting uh we were sitting in the plane
waiting for like at least an hour and
then they kept saying they just have to
finish the paperwork technical paper for
it to get approved and we can take off
and then the last message they told us
oh we have to get off the plane we have
to be deep planed it and have to wait
for a further notice so hopefully they
say just two to four hours two to four
hours I hope there's two hours fingers
crossed
we got sent to another Lounge just
across now Evan's gonna eat something
how do you feel
it's the best let's go
so we waited for over an hour
so you haven't heard anything
this is 30 minutes let's hope
we can get out we haven't been called to
the board so I don't think it's leaving
in 30 minutes oh no sadness
all right it's um just past 11. we've
been delayed for actually over three
hours yeah yeah three and a half an
hours you got time to bond together yeah
you know so we're gonna we've been
asking the we've been bugging the uh the
the people at the front desk to see uh
just to check the update but they they
don't know anything as well so we're
gonna go to the customer service and ask
them for asking to see what we should do
all right we will update you once we get
to know
[Music]
all right
the people there with the customer
service people they said they don't know
they're waiting as well so
and then we wanted to go to a flight
from London but it's all packed
so we just have to wait and see what's
gonna happen
foreign
we're happy I was almost right okay
we're not gonna get on and then they
call call for Paris uh the people to
board so let's go
all right it's an exactly same spot we
made it in Evan let's go exciting let's
go let's go I could sleep a little bit
oh we're gonna make it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
all right we have to land it both of us
did not sleep at all I was super tired I
tried to sleep I couldn't sleep I just
lie down and try to relax
um now we got out the custom was pretty
fast
yeah it was like we were out in like
less than 15 minutes anyhow right now
we're just waiting for the car went to
get the car and then we're gonna drive
to um Monsey Mitchell
we pick up the car
the it's kind of stressful though
because
the previous guy whoever rented is in
Arabic yes his air I don't know he's and
then the language in there but I'm
trying to figure out how to change it
back to English
you're gonna have to think back to your
Arabic schooling Nina and remember yeah
right
I'm just gonna guess everything so you
got it yeah we believe in you Nina lead
us to victory yeah right I figured it
out figured it out English everything is
in English now or you just suddenly
understand Arabic whatever everything is
in English you can see
okay
[Music]
are you doing okay Evan
I'm pretty good this tunnel's a little
crazy
are you tired uh I was I mean I'm tired
but I'm okay just okay really dark in
this tunnel okay
here's a coffee
so we're gonna stop for gas just we
don't really need one but we need to get
a coffee so might as well I just stop to
get gas and then get a coffee because
Evan desperately needs one and then now
we're gonna go back on the road when I
got out the car earlier to check where
which side is the gas tank
and then as soon as I opened the door I
thought I thought it's on my side
because the uh there's a cover usually
that's what the gas tank is but then
when Evan got I say nope that's the
electric one and then the gas tank one
was on his side so we cannot beat up the
the tank we're just gonna
we grab the coffee and and then hop on
the no hop on we're gonna go back we're
gonna go back
on the highway and then go to our
destination
[Music]
so Evan has been doing a lot of driving
I said I would drive you drive two hours
I'll drive two hours but you've been
driving the whole
time
yeah so anyways I I I try to
try to stay
[Music]
the ball he's the only ones right I want
to be
here with him oh so that oh he doesn't
get too tired oh
oh I'm working for my city okay well
well if my safety is you're safe I gotta
interpret it uh
okay so we're about an hour in
about an hour but now just over an hour
probably and then um yeah
yeah well we got about hour 40 but we're
gonna take a break in like two minutes
gas stop bathroom break and then the our
last trip our last hour and a half to
get there
excited I've been wanting to go here for
a long time
it's always been just a little too far
you know four hours away from Paris if
you're only going for a couple days to
Paris it never makes sense but we got 10
days for our 10-year anniversary so
first stop Michelle a beautiful little
Island village with my beautiful little
island wife
not really no beautiful little wife
perfect now let's go
we are a half an hour away
it's been a tiring right right for you
yeah just start to well starting to get
dark yeah it is 6 30 we're gonna be
there in half an hour
exciting yeah
good thing you didn't like it no it's
actually good because if it's dark it
will be very tough to to draw
yeah there's no street lights
me awake yeah feeding him snacks sad
hydrated
yeah and loved
[Music]
all right we literally just like 10
minutes away from where we park let's go
where we need to park and the the
shuttle took us into the hotel because
there's no parking inside the monsoon
I'm pretty sure that's sit there on the
hill way down there wait I don't know
you had it you had a glimpse for like a
second okay hold on you might see it as
we turn in the corner way in the
distance
way in the distance and
no no no no wow oh there see no behind
the trees wait there's that one tree in
the middle no oh now it's gone no it was
there all I see is dark yeah it's okay
it's fine it's fine we'll see it we'll
see you're there oh I see it but the
camera cannot see it look at that it's
so cool it is here that's where we're
going yeah
anyways thank you for interrupting oh
Alice Evan I was gonna say excited we as
we drove by this Village here it reminds
me of uh my childhood I was living in a
village we were like me and my nazia we
were living in a village not him but
like oh I'm from the village and you
know a lot a lot of time me and my
cousin we always like walk through Like
Houses like the old houses like here
this is in China and it kind of reminds
me of where I came from anyhow let's go
we were trying to find a parking lot it
was a little hard to tell anyways we
made it work and then we just hop on the
shuttle bus to the hotel
well we're here we just had to walk a
little bit Evan is super excited super
excited he's very happy to see you yes
this will become all water this is not a
like the tide comes in so it won't just
be beached but tomorrow at some point
it'll be all water so it goes to an
island
this is a cool entrance Evan
it looks like it's been filmed for a lot
of movies and or shows except it's
actually real
okay let's go
the the row it's very hard to
push your luggage to I'm shaking because
the row row at the luggage rolling on
the on the stones
[Music]
all right here we are
foreign
so we had to take the luggage up to the
hill and stairs I was I did not expect I
got really tired so we're walking uphill
cutting the luggage with us
had to climb the stairs
put the suitcase
[Music]
so this is our hotel room so there are
only like a very limited hotel in this
island when I bought this hotel they
were there's only this one is available
so I booked this one basically as soon
as you walk in I'm standing right at
this uh the door on the right hand side
it's a bathroom
just a toilet and then I got two twin
size because it's better to sleep in a
separate bed but still together separate
bed separate blanket guys take my tips
change your life change your life
together yeah and then right over here
is the shower room
and then desk
and over here is the closet and then a
TV that's it we basically just drop our
stuff there connect to Wi-Fi and then
come out to get some dinner because we
haven't really eaten anything today
except for this except for the snack
that we had in the car
[Music]
we just come to our hotel's restaurant
we were looking at the menu yeah I have
to use Google to translate it because I
don't know any french but I kind of
guess I understand kind of guess a
little bit I got half of it yeah
cheers
you try it
oh this is this is really sweet
oh yeah you can have this one
you tell me which one you like better
this one's really sweet though I don't
like sweet stuff yeah that's very sweet
it's almost like an ice cream yeah yeah
but I like I like you because you're
very sweet
[Music]
all right give it a try Nina
[Music]
try it
it's good very good creamy yeah yeah
Thai oyster no
these are great I love it
muscle lip cream sauce yummy
[Music]
good job
that's a that's a huge omelette Evan
this is what they're known for
the most family shell famous omelette
yeah try it holy cow
oh very fluffy
because we're eating an omelet for
dinner we're very very bite and [ __ ] you
okay we'll say you can't have omelette
for dinner right okay Nina's gonna try
the famous omelets There She Goes
it takes control of the fork just take
control
yeah very fluffy right yeah it's like
milk in your mouth yeah it's good okay
have your salmon let's try this salmon
veggies rice
shrimp
how are you feeling Evan
yeah
I know we haven't slept the whole day
almost three o'clock in the afternoon
for us yeah
2 45.
so we basically stayed up all night and
then halfway through the afternoon the
next day on that night so you just
haven't slept in two days
it's okay we'll get some sleep tonight
fingers crossed you know these medieval
hotels have great sound propane and air
conditioning and you know all of that so
it'll be a great sleep and wake up
tomorrow and have more greatness
in store could I even try your ice cream
oh what did you get
they're most famous for their salted
caramel salted caramel okay and then
whatever that's it and then he
recommended to have coffee with it okay
so it's not the caramels but this is the
go-to right here
[Music]
is that coffee at salted caramel no it's
not the caramel is it good it's good
yeah but I have an ice cream in a long
time dude what's the last time I have
ice cream I don't know like real ice
cream
it's been a while good yeah it's really
good coffee
all right
oh wow that's very popular which one do
you like the most salty
okay Nina taste test this is the coffee
wow it's very strong so I said very
coffee let me wash on my salad oh wow
it's that strong huh okay all right I
wasn't able to test this uh
my face is actually very red we just
finished dinner from all the alcohol
yeah
it looks like I have blush on
anyways you do maybe you're nervous I'm
very nervous talking to the camera
okay it was such a good meal yep that's
good meal we had a uh it was nice we had
some fun conversation conversation
let's hope hold my hands are you gonna
fall over what's happening I'm not gonna
fall over okay it was quite a good meal
good good chat yep and then we're gonna
maybe walk around or just go back to the
hotel room and then sleep
I need sleep would be good okay then
we'll just go go back okay sleep and
then tour tomorrow
are you are you drunk I'm tired
okay let's go back then
[Music]
okay
um I think we're gonna caught up the
night
uh we've been very tired Evan just took
a shower my face is very red still uh I
think they what what they call it Asian
blush Asian what do you call it Asian
amazingness okay anyways it's just like
if you have a glass or two glass of
alcohol you just turn very red so my
face is like cheeks here they're very
red anyhow we're gonna get ready for bed
because we haven't slept yesterday
because we were on the plane
yeah hopefully we get a good night's
sleep and then have an amazing day
tomorrow if you want to see what we do
seeing the mosa Michelle Abby as well as
going to Paris check the video right
there next to us I think it's the other
side Nina right there next to us I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe I
will see you there